team Mali has a problem
the algorithm that these University
students have built is failing to
connect with their robot and time is
running out
they're in Senegal competing against
students from across Africa it's an
annual event started in 2015 with a
mission to promote and develop
artificial intelligence built by young
people across the continent
the challenge this year is to show that
their software can guide a robot in a
field while identifying weeds among
crops
Samuel is a fourth year mechanical
engineering student from Nigeria
he started coding and developing
algorithms when he was just 13. the more
you learn how to solve problems the
better you become at thinking and from
there you can all start coding from
coding you cannot start building from
building you cannot start implementing
and deploying so you become very
successful
the United Nations is artificial
intelligence is fundamental to achieving
its sustainable development goals in
Africa but there are huge challenges
including a lack of relevant technical
skills inadequate infrastructure and
insufficient investment
we want Africa to be part of the
overall Innovation uh
map of the world and we want also to be
part of people that are building the
future
the tech startup firm concrete sits on a
Dusty back street in the Senegalese
Capital Dakar
they built an artificial intelligence
that has the potential to change
millions of lives across the continent
so for the purpose of showing you how
this works babakar here is pretending to
be a potential entrepreneur anywhere in
Africa and the AI that the company has
developed is asking babica a series of
questions
including what his passions are what his
budget is where he's from what his
catchment area is and what his time
frame is for potentially starting this
business and in just 45 seconds it's
going to come up with pretty much an
entire business plan
one of the biggest challenges the
company faces is so-called scaling up
which involves a lot of data and
computing power in areas of Africa where
that may not be technologically possible
the company goal is clear to be part of
a world where there is an under a
successful entrepreneur in every
household
mainly in Africa
back at the event team Zimbabwe are in
High Spirits and team Marley solved the
problem they earlier faced
a young African generation embracing an
often frighteningly fast-moving
technological World Charles Stratford Al
Jazeera Senegal